a popular Southern California amusement
park will open later today after a
wildfire prompted a dramatic evacuation
crews are battling at least six
different fires burning across
California this morning Janet shamlian
is at the Six Flags park that's in
Valencia that's northwest of Los Angeles
Jenna you have any idea have you heard
what started the fire good morning to
you
Gail good morning there is no official
cause yet but this area is a tinderbox
high temperatures and gusting winds are
creating perfect conditions here and
with the vacation season in full swing
the park was packed when it happened a
fast-moving brush fire pushed flames
dangerously close to Six Flags Magic
Mountain Sunday video on social media
showed hundreds of people streaming out
of the park some were still on rides
when thick smoke turned the sky dark it
was like getting in our eyes and like we
couldn't see for a little bit and then
like they gave us like these are masks
to wear so this is what they gave you
yeah so like we didn't put it on yeah I
put it on I I didn't want to smell it
that's pretty scary
park officials quickly evacuated guests
for safety reasons but fire officials
told some to stay in the parking lot due
to road closures
Claudia Aguilar was stuck in her car for
an hour was that frightening yes because
the fire was getting big the palms are
bringing this is one of several fires
throughout the state fueled by strong
winds at excessive heat north of
Sacramento more than 500 firefighters
worked to get the Sam fire under control
I'm racing home and I see this smoke and
it's oh gosh it's terrible in a
controversial move utility company PG&E
cut power to more than 20,000 in
Northern California as a precaution the
company is under increasing pressure
after an investigation found its power
lines paused last year's campfire which
killed more than 80 people we certainly
understand that
it's inconvenient for customers to be
without power we also want to keep these
communities safe so when these extreme
fire conditions call for it we're doing
a Public Safety power shut off utility
has restored power to most customers but
the threat here is not over there's an
excessive heat watch through Tuesday for
many areas here it's going to be a
hundred and four degrees today Tony all
right Janet thank you very much